terrorism, ebola virus or even and
development, hot topics
are not missing from the agenda of this
joint parliamentary assembly in
the hemicycle of MEPs but
also elected officials from 79 African,
Caribbean and Pacific countries,
as the co  president of
this assembly africa is
strategic in the affairs of the world
and cannot be ignored whether it is
fundamentalist terrorism,
nuclear proliferation and illegal trafficking
of all kinds or is in a
situation of fragility carrying
threats to  peace
stability africa today is one of the
theaters of globalization of
strategic and security challenges the sahel
darfur somalia the drc mali
nigeria niger horn of africa
and finally the islamic countries whose
murderous rage and  the macabre horror
have no limit to help
the countries of africa, the caribbean and the
pacific the union can in an
envelope of 35 billion  euros for
the period 2014-2020 of the payments
that MEPs wish to condition
there was a resolution of the
European Parliament case said it must be at
least 20% of the fact see these funds
for development aid be targeted
education  and health
and when we look in detail it is not
necessarily the case
so we push see so that each
state also takes responsibility africa as
we know it
yes it is roms offer advanced materials
upstream this match is particular in the
provinces in wawa  rhône ab the
valeo titles at 2,716 stupid and you how much
portuguese tapenade or value at
shows in african for this MEP
despite the economic crisis which is
hitting europe the budgets devoted to
development aid must not be questioned
I believe that what is
important for all European citizens
to understand is that it is
a policy that really aims to
defend our place in the world we
promote our values  ers of
democracy human rights the
values of tolerance solidarity all t
ese deputies will meet again the next
ay on the menu of the ebola discussions